two minutes until this reaching begin
few minutes
yes
lots of careful
yeah
I'll be here
much more
it
yeah
[Music]
so I want to start by acknowledging the
horrific tragedy in Minnesota of George
Floyd the the death of George Floyd is
absolutely tragic that video that we saw
that I saw that my staff saw that the
president saw and the president put out
a statement last night that at his
request the FBI and the Department of
Justice are already well into an
investigation as to the very sad and
tragic death in Minnesota of George
Floyd I have asked for this
investigation to be expedited and
greatly appreciate all of the work done
by law enforcement my heart goes out to
George's family and friends justice will
be served
I can tell you that as I'm briefing you
at this moment the president is
receiving a briefing from the Attorney
General
dobar on this and the Deputy Director of
the FBI so that is on going on as I
began this briefing secondly I want to
transition and to some news from SBA and
Treasury that was announced that today
the US Small Business Administration in
consultation with the US Treasury
Department announced that it is setting
aside 10 billion of round-2 funding for
the Paycheck protection program to be
lent exclusively to CDF eyes those are
Community Development financial
institutions CDFIs work to expand
Economic Opportunity in low-income
communities by providing access to
financial products and services for
local residents and businesses so we're
encouraged to see that and then finally
before taking your questions I wanted to
address what has been going on on
Twitter and with social media I believe
it is time to quote get the facts about
Twitter and other social media platforms
targeting their bias against President
Trump and conservatives online if we
were to judge the bias of Twitter and
its top employees by their own words the
case would be an easy one to make
Twitter's head of site integrity has
tweeted that there are quote actual
Nazis in the White House and no
fact-check label is ever applied to this
absolutely outrageous offensive and
false claim made against the White House
and its employees but let's judge
Twitter based on their actions not based
on the words of its top employees and
its act
Asians are no better President Trump
recently received a so-called fact check
label for a tweet it was a false fact
check in an accurate fact check but
nevertheless Twitter moved forward with
it
dance Covino the deputy chief of staff
here was the first user in the history
of Twitter to receive a so-called quote
manipulated media label for posting a
video that played a verbatim clip it is
no coincidence that these two
unbelievable interventions by Twitter
were targeted against the President of
the United States and one of the
presidents top advisors this is bias in
action and while big tech is quick to
censor the president quick to censor
some of his top employees they they are
very reluctant it seems to label some of
the actions by Chinese officials some of
the misinformation that has been spread
by China for example to move off of
Twitter and move to Google they created
a search engine search engine for the
Chinese Communist Party which
blacklisted searches for human rights
and allowed for easy surveillance
Facebook and Twitter have both taken
paid advertising that spread
disinformation about China's mass
imprisonment of religious minorities and
twitter has allowed Chinese officials to
use its platforms to spread in
misinformation about the coronavirus
undermine the pro-democracy protest in
Hong Kong and more and then back in
March a Chinese official began spreading
a conspiracy theory on Twitter an
egregious one that our US military was
responsible for the spread of the corona
virus and that tweet that disinformation
it took all the way until today when we
raised concerns about it to get a fact
check so they appear to be very hastily
eager to censor President Trump and some
of his employees but a little reluctant
when it comes to China it's a bit
befuddle
no one believes in the First Amendment
more than the president the president
will take action to ensure that big tech
does not stifle free speech and that the
rights of all Americans to speak tweets
and posts are protected and finally I
just want to note one other action of
Twitter that I learned just before
walking out here that on
Moeller reports their anti-trump
headlines were anti-trump by a ratio of
76 to 1 that's extraordinary and it's
not just biased aimed at President Trump
and his employees it's also aimed at
everyday Americans it's aimed at the
movie unplanned as Twitter suspended
their account and then came up with an
excuse in the aftermath and then just
another example that liberals are
allowed to incite violence against the
Covington kids who were in the end
proven right on their video was taken
out of context and yet these individuals
were led we're allowed by Twitter to
incite violence it's very disturbing to
see so those are some of the president's
concerns and with that I will take
questions Jim
yesterday the u.s. hit a hundred
thousand deaths from the corona virus
that happened at around 6 o'clock
yesterday evening it took until about
9:00 in the morning for the President to
recognize that on Twitter what took him
so long if the president recognized that
landmark before we even hit it the
president that was after all it was the
impetus behind him lowering the flag to
half-staff he did that for several days
I mean and that was an acknowledgment of
that number approaching and he
acknowledged it in a tweet this morning
we hit 100,000 yesterday evening and it
took 13 hours some odd hours to for him
to recognize that and tweet about it
foreign advance of that benchmark as I
noted he lowered the flag to half-staff
the president has said you know you
mentioned a hundred thousand but the
president has said one death is too many
he takes us very seriously he said
before this is the hardest part of his
presidency it's something that no one
wanted to see happen on Twitter shooting
the president defection especially this
president who has made so many false and
misleading statements that has put you
know fact checkers to work across the
world
I mean he's muttered some 18,000 false
or misleading
that's according to the Washington Post
if there's any president out there as
you'd be factoring any political leader
out there should be fact check isn't it
president clump and aren't you trying to
silence fact-checking by going after
Twitter like this well first I would say
I disagree with them all if not almost
all of those assertions that you're
making there because look if you're
going to get into the fact-checking
business there's no one that should be
fact-checked more than the mainstream
media that has been continually wrong
about a number of things to give you a
list of some of the most egregious ones
that ABC News in December of 2017
falsely reported that Flynn would
testify that the president directed him
during the campaign to make contact with
the Russians that was false in 2017 your
network CNN botched their WikiLeaks
email exclusive and were forced to make
on our Corrections
CNN's Jim sciutto another CNN one
dropped a fictional bombshell in 2018
July claiming that Michael Cohen would
tell federal investigators that the
president knew of the Trump Tower
meeting and there are many more not to
just put the onus on CNN there so if
anyone needs to be fact checked I think
it should be the media their news
outlets that make mistakes from time to
time we own up to those mistakes we
correct we do on a regular basis the
president never owns up to any of his
false or misleading statements were
outright lies you have pledged in this
briefing room to never lie to the
American people are you saying that the
president of the United States has never
lied to the public before I'm around the
president his intent is always to give
truthful information to the American
people and you mentioned that the media
apologizes for their mistruths I mean
I'm sitting here looking at other
headlines in New York Times saying there
aren't enough ventilators to cope with
the corona virus in fact we had an
excess of ventilators we've shipped
around the world Washington Post us
Health System is showing why it's not
ready for a corona virus pandemic we
were already there's many more I could
get to I could on the corona virus
specifically I could spend the time
going through these so I don't think
that's what the American people want to
hear yes
on the Minnesota case does the president
agree with the firings of the four
police officers that does he believe
that they should be prosecuted I haven't
talked to him about that specifically
but let me tell you this that you know
he was very upset when he saw that video
I was on Air Force One I don't know if
it was the first time he saw it but he
certainly saw it again on Air Force One
he was a very upset by it it was
egregious appalling tragic and it
prompted him to pick up the phone or the
chief of staff to pick up the phone and
say we need to expedite what it was
already an FBI investigation he wants
justice to be served Thanksgiving can
you give us an update on when the
president plans to sign the EO on
Twitter and social media and can you
also give us an update on his plans for
China and Hong Kong is there an order
come
as well so thank you for the question
first I would note with regard to the
timing of the EEO that should be later
this afternoon is what we're hoping for
hopefully before 5:00 p.m. but again it
could change it's still under in the
works but we are getting closer with
regard to Hong Kong I would just say
breeder eight what I said last two days
ago but I would also say that China's
decision to impose a new national
security law in hong kong lies in direct
conflict conflict with its international
obligations under the principles of the
legally binding un registered
sino-british joint declaration and that
secretary Pompeo determined that hong
kong does not warrant different
treatment under US laws because hong
kong no longer remains sufficiently
autonomous from the PRC and then
anything further I Department for now
and is the White House going to treat
bills or does the White House see any
concerns about bills that have been
passed by proxy is not being
constitutional so we would at first let
me say we would encourage Nancy Pelosi
and the Democrats and others to come
back to the hill it's more productive to
have those members here the Senate has
convened the house can do the same and
they can do it in person but with regard
to the weavers that's a very important
question we haven't received the bill
yet so the president hasn't been able to
look through it and I won't get ahead of
him on announcing one way or the other
on that but I would note that the Trump
administration continues to take actions
to hold the CCP accountable for its
highly repressive campaign against the
we Gers and other religious and ethnic
minorities okay thank you
on that seems in order to achieve herd
immunity you need about eighty percent
of people to get this vaccine
currently only about 50% of Americans
say they'll work they'll receive it so
will the administration make the vaccine
mandatory so the vaccine let me just
note that we're working aggressively to
get one and we would like to get one by
the end of the year everything does not
depend on a vaccine I've axioms an
important component of this but there
are also therapeutics we're seeing
there's not necessarily a tie to
reopening and an increase in cases so
that's encouraging and I would refer you
further to Alexei czar who's made
extensive comments on a vaccine and
innocence here if you guys will make it
mandatory use your federal powers how
you'll use them potentially to encourage
people to get this vaccine because if
you don't have herd immunity
elderly people immunocompromised folks
they may not be able to go about their
business again yeah I would have to talk
to the president I haven't talked to him
about his views on making it mandatory
or not so I'd have to talk to him and
get back to you on that yes
Thank You Kelly I wanted to ask you a
question first of all about the comments
in your statement that you made the
conclusion of your comments in regards
to George Floyd you said that justice
will be served
what do you mean by that do you mean
that those officers who that fire should
be arrested do you mean by that that
those officers who have been fired
should be prosecuted do you mean that
those officers who made fire should be
convicted what do you mean by justice
should be served yes sir I'll leave that
to the justice system to work out the
good president in the president's
statement so I'd refer you back to his
statement but he's being briefed on this
right now and you know we'll have more
announcements as they come in regards to
what you said in your statement in
regards to the executive order I realize
it hasn't come out yet and I realize but
we haven't seen the language
but we have seen reports I work for Fox
and we've seen reports that it relates
to the section 230 the Communications
Decency Act and interestingly enough
former Vice President Joe Biden has also
called for the repeal of section 230 he
says that it should be revoked
immediately but as you know an executive
order does not chop the law the
executive order can't for instance
repeal the law it can't in any way of
men the law so what would be the intent
behind this executive order without
getting ahead of what the president
intends to sign yeah I don't want to get
ahead of that but one thing I will say
more broadly you reference that section
I think that's that would it be included
and what I'm about to say there are
various shields in place that
essentially shield some of these social
media companies and allow them to censor
conservative users and we're not able to
see what happens behind those shields
that section was one of those shields
you mentioned so we're looking at ways
to remove those shields to shed some
light on what is happening as some of
the decision making behind the scenes
that's generally and broadly the idea
but I won't get ahead on any specific
announcements that should come hopefully
before 5:00 p.m. John follow up on Jim's
question in fact checking at Twitter but
but first a clarification has the
president spoken to the family of George
Floyd not to my knowledge my if he did
Oh without my knowledge that could have
happened but not to my knowledge do you
know he intends to well you get back to
us on that I didn't ask him and I can
get back to you on that and regarding
the the fact-checking me that the
president clearly said things in these
tweets that are not
Kru does do you not acknowledge that no
I don't acknowledge that he for instance
the Governor of California is sending
out ballots to millions of people anyone
living in the state no matter who they
are how they got there that is not true
California is sending out about absentee
ballots to registered voters not to
anybody yes that's just not true
so let me address this in detail on the
issue of ballots
um and I'm gonna lay out some of the
president's concerns and in that I will
get to the California example first I
want to know that there is a Pew study
done that shows there's plenty of reason
to believe that mass and the mass
mailing system that there is fraud they
estimated that approximately 24 million
one out of every eight voters registered
in the US are no longer valid or are
significantly inaccurate so these are
people on who are on voter registrations
that have not been maintained that have
not been kept up more than 1.8 million
have been deceased they estimated and
then when you look and drill down and
some of some of the examples that we've
seen in states Nevada just I read about
this last week and it just really struck
me as a perfect example of what the
president is concerned about with
mail-in ballots and the fraud that can
be inherent in that there were ballots
on because Nevada mass mailed them out
to voter rolls that were piling up in
apartment complexes outside of apartment
complexes in Las Vegas sitting around in
trash cans this is how we're protecting
ballots it's extraordinary postal
workers one 36 year old 36 year veteran
carrier said she's never seen anything
like these influx of absentee ballots
all of the people had moved or died when
she set out to deliver on her first
delivery route and this happened just
recently you can go read the articles
from last week she found 65 ballots of
people who had moved her diet on her
second carry 100 and then as the week
progressed thousands just sitting and
crates I mean this is extraordinary this
is not how we should be protecting us
ballots in South Carolina
Dems the Democrats sued to force a rush
transfer of mail-in voting and this
happened again recently I think it was
last week and now
ballots for South Carolina turned up in
Maryland there's another example of 700
suspicious mail-in ballots and Dallas
and an individual charged with
second-degree felony illegal voting and
he's accused of visiting a woman in
April to collect her blank absentee
ballot filling it out and forging her
signature I mean this is extraordinary
and then you go on there's a New Jersey
example of over 3,000 ballots that were
seemingly set aside and going to
California you mentioned California is
one of those states that notorious for
ballot harvesting and in 2018 the
Registrar in Orange County said that
they reported that his office had people
dropping off maybe a hundred or 200
ballots at a time and somehow in LA
County a hundred twelve percent of LA
County is a registered to vote so the
problem is this when you don't clean
your register and you send out your
entire register Auto send out these
ballots they end up in trash cans like
in Nevada they are subject to fraud and
that is extremely troubling so Kelly I
asked you a very specific question the
president said that California was
sending out ballots to everybody in the
state that is a false statement it is
not correct
will the president correct that
acknowledge that what he said was simply
not true there is an executive order
that was put into place recently by
Gavin Newsom that would auto send to
voter rolls and that would lead to what
the president was suggesting excuse me
Kelly to do to registered voters those
it's not to everybody is to register to
vote yes to everyone including dead
people on the voter rolls including to
the mysterious 112 percent in LA County
that's not that's not just everyone
that's everyone plus an extra 12 percent
and if you're not concerned about that
I'm sorry I mean the media is very
concerned about the security of our
elections but when it comes to mail-in
ballots all of a sudden the concern for
election security just melts away
yourself
Frank research on on mail-in ballots
research has shown that one it doesn't
benefit either party
it increases voter participation
secretary of the state of both parties
are still pursuing it and fraud is is
not widespread and so why is the
president continuing to tweet about this
and to give the impression that there's
widespread froggies in the ballot when
he himself use the mail and Valerie big
question is some are concerned that the
president may be laying the groundwork
to cast out on the election is that what
he's doing by bringing this up well I
appreciate you bringing up this question
and specifically the component about the
president using mail-in ballots there's
an important distinction and I think
it's lost upon a lot of people but it's
important to make is that the president
is okay with mail and voting so long as
you have a reason he's not okay with
mass mail and voting where you Auto send
as I said to all of these voter rolls
with people who are dead that are
subject to fraud that is the case we saw
I've listed off for you I think three of
the five examples I gave you we're from
just this week and last week so this
does happen and research have shown
Stanford University did a research study
that showed that there wasn't widespread
fraud in these vote-by-mail and that it
didn't benefit either party and increase
voter participation so why would the
president be against that yeah it is
subject to both parties this can hurt
both parties I would note that a
bipartisan Commission led in part by
President Jimmy Carter a Democrat
concluded that mail-in ballots quote
remain the largest source of potential
voter fraud so moving the entire country
to that system doesn't make sense and
doing so in a hurried fashion ahead of
November just go look at the Democrat
Iowa caucus and how it worked out when
they tried to move to a new system
trying to miss out on the results of the
election finally I know he's certainly
not doing that and I would finally note
there's an additional concern that was
very well laid out by the Wall Street
Journal editorial board that in 2016
minorities and first-time voters were
more likely to have mail-in ballots
thrown out so that is
another troubling concern in factory
under nineteen thousand of those total
votes were rejected yes thank you
back in November President Trump left
the Walter Reid said it was for phase
one of his physical when does he plan to
complete phase two and release the
results of the public yeah I don't have
an update on the physical but because
you asked that I'll specifically inquire
about that today and try to get back to
you when he does yes yes thank you thank
you for doing this I wanted to ask you
about president has completed his two
weeks of head of security
have you spoken to him what he is
feeling about is better
what's his feedback about that I did and
thank you I know that you emailed me a
question to that effect and I didn't
have time to follow up with you via
email but on because I saw that I went
into him just before coming out here and
I asked him that and he said quote he's
feeling perfect quote he's feeling
absolutely great after taking this
regimen and quote he would take it again
um if he thought that he was exposed so
he is feeling very good and I also would
point folks there's a very very
well-done piece it's very thorough with
a lot of medical experts laying out
about the prophylaxis use of
hydroxychloroquine by Tina hesseman say
at science news or gets very well done
she talks about the nearly 200 clinical
trials around the world including 28
involving health care workers I'm in
fact at Henry Ford Hospital in Michigan
3,000 health care workers are taking it
as part of a trial and there's some
really excellent information there about
um you know the the use of prophylaxis
prism of Indian Americans doctors have
been writing I have seen some of those
letters they are supporting president
taking hydroxy
some of them so taking a time so you
seen those two yeah yeah well there's a
lot it's not specific to the president
these doctors but they just talk in
general about what they've seen for
instance a Sarah Lofgren an infectious
disease doctor at the University of
Minnesota Medical School in Minneapolis
they're testing hydroxychloroquine dare
to prevent covin 19 and she said when
used alone we're not seeing major issues
out of the thousands of patients we're
not seeing things that some people are
concerned about and I would just note
that it's important of course always if
taking hydroxychloroquine get a
prescription from your doctor doctors
are the ones that need to be prescribing
this but that being said I think that's
some of the hyperbole around this drug
that has been on the market for 65 years
been approved for use and three other
maladies and has been approved for
off-label use when there's a lot of
hyperbole about this being unsafe some
of the things I've seen reported out
there there are consequences deterring
people from being recruited into actual
clinical trials I have some quotes from
New York epidemiologist and others
conducting trials saying they're having
trouble recruiting people because some
of the myths that are out there so it's
important to note that this drug has
been safely used by millions of people
for a long time in China President
yesterday tweeted about he was to
mediate between us and sorry India and
China on the border dispute you know
China has two very clearly very
aggressive Louis's enables in the last
few weeks until the South China Sea you
must have seen on the Indian water side
what's the message visit has to these
countries
yeah I'd refer you back to the
president's tweet on that one yeah
question thanks Kaylee we saw reports
that before swearing in genre with his
DNI rick rinaldi class to buy the trove
of documents related to the russian
investigation president hinted that
those could be made public sometime soon
does the director plan on doing that
anytime in your agency those I believe
are under a process of review by the DOJ
so I'll refer to them on that yes Tom do
you have a question I thought I saw you
had your hand raised no thank you
I want to ask you about Russia's recent
actions in Libya the u.s. AFRICOM has
been issuing statements recently about
u.s. actions there and in their
statements they're saying that Russia is
clearly trying to tip the scales and its
favor in Libya just like in business
area by deploying military elf aircraft
likely to provide close air support and
offensive fires for the wagonette Vagner
group that is supporting the vs Allen a
fight against the internationally
recognized governments do you have with
the White House position on this if you
agree with the us-africa assessment that
their actions there were some actions in
Libya are destabilizing the region yeah
we encourage de-escalation in Libya and
for more I'd refer you to the DoD you
know if Joe Scarborough were innocent
couldn't he see the president for
defamation and then in turn curtain
president Trump's attorneys immediately
deposed Joe Scarborough for and allowing
to go on under oath and explain how
nervous 28 year old woman
found dead by his desk with multiple
skull fractures
would the president welcome a defamation
suit from Joe Scarborough so in that I
would just refer you back to some of my
previous comments that the audio and the
Don Imus show is very disturbing where
there is a lot of laughing and joking
about this matter that certainly is not
a laughing and joking I mean do you
think that scarborough has grounds to do
so so I no further comments other than
to just point back to the Don Imus audio
who hasn't yes we know the states first
notified that they would have to take
the lead in koban 19 testing I know the
CBC was working on early on January
February the problem of the test boom of
the state's old pay you prepare and take
the lead here and testing your
population so I don't have a precise
date for you but I know the way the
process went or the states came up with
the plans that they thought they would
need to have adequate testing in order
to reopen those plans were given to us
and Admiral JA meticulously went through
all of those plans ensured that we had
enough supply to shore up those plans
that states had and to make sure that
the states had enough to safely reopen
so that was how the process went and the
president has done really extraordinary
work with testing three hundred four
hundred thousand tests per day is a
pretty good number a very good number I
would say more than 15 million done
beating the world and testing numbers
and under 10 percent positivity is at
least the barometer given by the w-h-o
as what's necessary and nationally we're
at under 10 percent positivity in fact
we're at 7.5% positivity rate so we are
doing quite well on testing is there
anyone who hasn't gotten a question
because last yeah thank you has the
president heard from his counterparts
regarding the g7 summit is it
we need to take place in June at the
White House we do aim for it to take
place then it's gotten positive
reception I enquired about this two days
ago and was told it's getting very
positive reception from world leaders so
we do intend for that to take place here
you yourself have been able to vote by
mail several times do you think anyone
with health concerns who has health
concerns about going to the polls I
should have that same right so what I
would note again is the distinction
between absentee voting and having a
reason and mass mail out voting or
ballots are sent in a widespread fashion
to people who are dead but on voting
rolls and those ballots end up in trash
cans
that's a state-by-state consideration
I'll leave it to states to determine
what is a valid reason but there are you
know if you're an elderly person you
know set of health considerations for
all for a lot of their residents and if
they want to pursue that track is there
anything wrong with that again I mean
you're asking I assume you're asking
with relation to the pandemic that's
going on none of us know where we're
going to be in November I'd first note
that we don't have a crystal ball but
what I would say is that there are real
concerns when you don't do in-person
voting in South Carolina is a great
example where Democrats literally sued
to force rush mail in voting and what
happened you had ballots from South
Carolina ending up in Baltimore that is
not a tenable system and as states start
to reopen and we see people out at
beaches in Florida and we're not seeing
these mast spikes and we see people
safely going to restaurants and social
distancing and washing their hands and
doing all the wonderful mitigation
techniques put forward by our experts
they're reopening society and they're
doing so safely and I think there's a
way to continue our great civic duty of
showing up and voting I'm in a way that
is safe and the same way it's safe to
you had a restaurant it's safe to go to
a beach we can vote in a safe fashion
and I think that's something that is
good and to be celebrated as we head to
November all right I think I took
everyone's question
you